[Musique]
d'une Jolie
fille sur
aigre pour quelqu'un
nuit le soir
attacher elle est partie elle a plié
bagages et puis
ven
tourne le
[Musique]
page elle était Belle
pourtant si j'avais pu la
garder le
soir comme une
enfant Moi je l'aurais merci
[Musique]
IL fait partie
l'oiseau c'est la
faute qui veut que les
oiseaux
s'envole Au Grand
ter l'amour est
[Applaudissements]
À
s'installer On Ne prend pas le
les temps de s'habituer
[Musique]
parfois on sent qu'on va
flanker sur les sert les
dents IL faut
oublier elle était Belle
pourtant si j'avais pu la
[Musique]
garder le
soir comme une
enfant Moi Je l'aurais
bé IL est parti
[Musique]
l'oiseau
c'est la faute
PR tu veux que les
oiseaux
s'envole Au Grand
terre elle était Belle
[Musique]
pourtant c'est drôle je l'oublie
Je te comprends
va ne te
retour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
passer